[Applause]
we must have been the two tallest guys
in late night
oh yeah let me ask you something you're
you're uh cause
first of all that suit you did not get
that off the rack no no no no no
no you have someone who makes these for
you yes you are six feet
nine six nine that amazes me because
i'm used to being fairly tall i'm about
a little over six
four if i was in the nba i'd be a speedy
little guy wouldn't i
i'd be like one of those little speedy
guys exactly in today's game you would
be very short
yeah i'd be a small untalented man
in the nba my small height would not be
the only problem there'd be other
problems
i still want to say that yeah you said
that yeah thank you but uh but i'm
curious
uh this is this causes problems for you
everyone thinks what would be so great
to be magic johnson but
six feet nine inches tall you've
actually broken
you broke equipment once at an amusement
park didn't you
tell us about that what did you do man
what happened was i got on a
i was going on a roller coaster and you
know the bars that
lock you in i had to fold my legs and
sit like this you know like
really down low so the bar could come
over and lock me in
right well it threw the timing off the
whole
uh whole roller coaster so everyone was
killed
what a wonderful story basically just
because you had to ride a roller coaster
so it took us like 10 minutes to get me
in there right right and so when i
when we finished the ride it was about
eight blue coats waiting for me
yeah and i was like uh oh what happened
i thought something happened
right so they pulled me aside said uh mr
johnson
you can never ride the roller coaster
again
that's so sad oh very sad so then you
went to the teacups and broke those
yeah i just went around everything at
the park i should have broke
but i had a good time though it was
experience now you did a
i don't know who came up with the
nickname magic
but if you're going to pick a nickname i
would think that's one of the better
ones to have
you know because a lot of people get
saddled with a nickname and then that is
it
so did you did you have someone i mean
who first of all came up with the idea
let's call this guy
magic was that you no it wasn't me it
was a sports writer
writer back in lansing michigan when i
was 15 years old right and he said hey i
want to give you a nickname and you know
at 15. yeah
what do you know right nothing really
right right and so
i said okay cool and my friends are all
laughing at me so the guy said
somebody's already called dr j and big e
that was alvin hayes
right i want to call you magic so i
looked at my boys they looked at me
is this guy kidding right right i
thought he was kidding too and the next
day he wrote the article magic and
it stuck everything that's giving that
guy a lot of power what if he had said
stinky you know i think you're stinky
you know and then that sticks and like
no matter what you achieve they're like
good job
stinky and you're like uh you had a
different nickname for a while that you
got rid of isn't that right yeah i used
to oh man a few of them
my my family call me junebug
see that would not be nearly and then
junebug won his fifth
nba title exactly go junebug
go that just wouldn't be very good
you're right
and so you know little e ej you know
right right and then the lakers they all
called me buck
right so that was my name with the
lakers right right
because magic you can't beat that no you
can't be this it's great it's been good
to me
yes my mom she doesn't like it but it's
been great
why doesn't your mom like it well you
know of course they give you
ervin and they won what's wrong with
irvin
let me talk to her yeah i'll explain to
her irvin's okay but
no it's not as good as magic well the
funny thing is conan irvin
is not the reason that she lives in that
big house now i had to keep explaining
right magic
magic paid for this kevin's working in a
shoe store
somewhere now you are a uh
highly not only achieved uh great things
uh
as an athlete an amazingly successful
businessman and i was looking at your
accomplishments today you own
33 starbucks and that's on one city
block
which is a problem by the way exactly if
we have enough uh you have a chain of
movie theaters
is that right 24-hour gyms you're part
owner of the lakers right
and then you own tgi fridays is that
right
that's it do you go to tgi fridays yes i
do
right right there's some good stuff at
tgi friday there's some good stuff
uh and you have fat burger restaurants
yeah it's a southern california
hamburger
stand which we have 47 units i used to
go to fat burger all the time
and then i was wondering like do they
ever try and get you to change it to
sound more health conscious even if the
burger's the same
you might not want to call it fat burger
yes
[Laughter]
but you know my favorite is you are
partners in a bank
with janet jackson yeah we're business
partners i see it first of all that
sounds like the coolest bank in the
world
where are you going janet jackson and
magic johnson's bank i want to come
that sounds like a cool bank the other
thing is i think if the problem with
having a bank
is that if someone hits you up for money
and you own a bank it's very hard to say
i don't know it's not a good time for me
right now you own
a bank you know what i mean
they can say like just take me to any
one of your atms and it's been hard to
turn people down because of that reason
right exactly
right especially the relatives right
right you own a bank
i don't want to hear that you don't have
any money right now now one thing that
set you apart which i think is a great
thing
especially in when you consider the nba
today is that you never
cursed you never trash talked no when
you were a player
but people must have trash talked at you
and how did you handle that would you
just try and let it just
wash over you how did you tune that out
when someone's right there and they're
just giving you a hard time
and they're saying all kinds of nasty
stuff to try and get into your head how
did you respond
well it was funny because they'd be
running their mouth and i just say
i just point up at the scoreboard
because nine times out of ten we were
beating at the same time yeah
yeah so that's all you had to do i
thought you're going to say and then you
pressed a button and it fell on the guy
you're like pretty good
[Music]
no i i just let the scoreboard do the
talking because
when you're winning at that time i
didn't trash talk the biggest
trash talkers ever in history of
basketball is michael jordan and larry
bird
right but they can back it up yep see
that's what's
so great about basketball players in my
day
michael jordan could back it up yeah he
would let you know he's killing you and
he would kill you he would score 50.
and larry bird would say i'm gonna score
40 tonight and go out and score 40.
right
and and win the game now guys talk trash
and they can't play
you see but you know what that's exactly
what i would be if i was in the nba
i would be that guy like that and then i
would accomplish nothing
but i'd be trash talking more than
anybody yes yes and that's what we have
more today
than we have actual great basketball
players right right so we have to change
that sort of speed now let's talk about
who's got game this is an interesting
idea this is uh this is your show
tell us about it it's on mtv it's a
street ball reality show on mtv starting
this sunday at 10 30
and actually snoop dogg show premieres
before my show
and uh what it is we went around the
country and casted
different uh players from around the
country and these are guys that that are
amazing players but they play
just on the street they play in courts
just around the country
at their hometown and they never uh
played in the nba
or any professional league and this is
their shot this is their chance to be on
tv for the first time
people can watch them play because
street ball is really big
like in new york it's really popular
here in chicago you go crowds gather and
watch these games yeah
and these guys have names too they have
helicopter and this and that so
uh white chocolate and they have
different type of white chocolate yeah
yeah i wish i had grabbed that one
late night with white chocolate
and they're legends yeah and they're
they're like michael jordan
in their hometown sure and so uh they
all compete against each other compete
against each other for a hundred
thousand dollars and a court
renamed and refurbished in their
hometown and so
there'll be uh one winner after the the
in the tenth
episode so it's amazing and you have
women in there too women we have ten
guys two women
and we also tell the backstory of them
as well we follow them around
to their hometown as well as they all
live in the same place so
you know that's a part of all these
reality shows make them hate each other
by having to share a bathroom yes and
and you know what's funny in sports
and in this show they end up supporting
the winner
right really because that's what sports
is about
we really respect the person who is the
best like
no i don't hate michael jordan he was
the best i didn't hate larry bird
you know we just liked each other on the
court when we went after the
championship
right but at the end of the day we
respect each other because
he's a talented guy you have to give it
up to talented players
much different than in other arenas
where
you know they dislike people right right
or they try and run them down or say
they could never take me oh yeah that's
trash talking yeah that's just my whole
mentality
that's how i am i'm like what are you
talking about support the guy no
run them down you've got it all wrong
magic
who's got game premieres this sunday
night at 10 30 on
mtv and we just loved having you on the
show thank you very much see you again
anytime
anytime magic johnson tom green coming
up we'll take a break we'll be right
back